[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone its Peter Brown standing in
for freelance reviewer Heidi camps for
her review of Fire Emblem echos shadows
of Valencia Fire Emblem echoes a remake
of a very early game in this series is a
departure of sorts from what most
veteran players expect from a Fire
Emblem game on 3ds rather than
emphasizing character relationships and
story dialogue echoes puts his focus on
long-term and short-term strategy and
strength building the end result is a
fresh take on the Fire Emblem strategy
formula and one that ranks among the
best in the 3ds library echoes follows
the dual leads of on and Celica
a pair of youths that bear a strange
crest upon their hands they bond
together as children in a tiny farming
village only to be torn apart by a
sudden dramatic event many years after
the fact you're in control of both
characters in their respective armies in
search of a reunion amongst a conflict
ridden yarn spun of large scale Wars
hidden pasts and shocking truths while
the story is classic Fire Emblem fare
the emphasis here is centered firmly on
the saga of Amon Celica with only a few
brief interludes that shift focus to
other army members the characters you
welcomed into your ranks and interact
with are charming and likable Bunch and
almost all in-game character text is
voiced as well which adds appreciable
personality
dicks you'll interest pigs huh who the
hell are you players more accustomed to
recent Fire Emblem games like Awakening
and fates may feel a bit disappointed in
the lack of side character interactions
you don't pair off characters and echoes
as you would in those games while
character to character support
conversations do still exist they're
much shorter and happen strictly during
combat while this may be disappointing
to some overall it helps cement the
story focus on the two leads in the
various warring factions of Fire Emblem
echos world while most of echos takes
place on grid-based turn driven
battlefields you'll also spend a lot of
time navigating an overworld map with
two armies one led by aam and the other
by Celica each with a different group of
soldiers under their lead you'll have to
manage resources weaponry and stat
building across two seperate teams
explorable towns castles shrines forts
and dungeons are unique to echoes and
while interactions with most areas are
somewhat limited basically restricted to
examining environments with a cursor
dungeons offer a far more interesting
twist for the seer
dungeons are explored on foot from a
third-person perspective you scout for
secret passages and smash pots and
crates for loot all while avoiding or
seeking out battles against roaming
enemies touching a foe takes you to a
traditional Fire Emblem battle but once
you fill your opponents it's right back
to exploring these areas serve as a
great addition that offer variety beyond
simply stringing together a series of
battles while still keeping the
narrative focus on the core story
I'll face down thieves or rogues any day
but terrace terrors are different hello
Bowie how can you be so scared of spooks
and spirits at your age shove off would
you a man can't help what gives him
fright echoes has some crucial
differences from other Fire Emblem games
that had interesting layers to army
management in combat as well
characters can only carry one item at a
time forcing you to carefully consider
if a special weapon a restorative item
or armaments like a shield and ring
would be ideal to carry magic has
learned through levelling up rather than
buying tomes and uses character hit
points to cast making high-powered
spells a potentially risky proposition
combat skills are learned by keeping
specific items equipped in battle for
long periods of time and are tied to
individual pieces of gear meaning you
can't just learn a skill and then react
whip your weapon as usual stamina wears
down as characters fight in take damage
degrading their stats and combat
capabilities unless they replenish it
with food medicine or offerings to the
goddess Milla finally the
rock-paper-scissors style weapon
triangle of modern Fire Emblem games is
gone entirely swords can now clash with
spheres on equal footing these are all
serious deviations from other Fire
Emblem games and they might take a bit
of time to get used to but they result
in a Fire Emblem game that has a very
distinct feel you'll need to really stop
and think about weapon distribution and
upgrades consider how to effectively use
certain classes when to take time with
optional fights to build character
levels and so on Echo's battles are
generally difficult too which makes
conquering some of the game's toughest
battles relatively unscathed feel like a
real accomplishment while the game's
difficulty level makes formulating a
sound strategy highly rewarding there
are times when grinding for experience
becomes a necessary evil yet it still
manages to feel worth it when you manage
to pull off a victory against unlikely
odds pride inhalation come in equal
measure
[Music]
very good right helping you to secure
those feelings is a brilliant new
addition to gameplay called Mulas turn
wheel which effectively acts as a rewind
button during battle missed several
attacks in a row you can opt to spin
back time a few turns and take a totally
new approach instead you can rewind time
as much or as little as you like
provided you still have enough cogs and
reserve for that battle this wonderful
system allows you to take back critical
combat mistakes without having to reset
a long and arduous battle and is a
tremendous boon in both casual and
classic modes with perma death once you
run out of cogs though you'll have to
restart the level and take back mistakes
adding yet another nice layer of
strategy to this mechanic is it really
worth a cog to re-roll for a critical
hit or should you save it for when you
plan your final assault on the tough as
nails enemy commander only you can make
the call Fire Emblem echoes is a
fantastic remake departure from modern
Fire Emblem staples what it lacks in
interpersonal character relationships
and user control dating it makes up for
immediate challenging strategy gameplay
fun exploration sequences and a tighter
overall narrative it may not be the sort
of game that fans of recent Fire Emblem
games are used to but it thrives for
what it is a challenging tactics game
that puts combat front and center
[Music]
you expected